(Música)
Las tortugas marinas son milagrosas.
En primer lugar, nos acompañan
desde el Jurásico tardío,
hace unos 150 millones de años.
Compañeras de los dinosaurios,
han sobrevivido al desafío de los eones
que aún existen, cuando muchos otros
han terminado su carrera evolutiva.
En segundo lugar, a lo largo siglos y hasta hoy,
cada adulto de tortuga marina
ha superado los pronósticos,
y existen producto de la casualidad,
la destreza y la capacidad.
A lo largo de sus vidas las tortugas enfrentan retos:
Primero, son depositadas en forma de huevos del tamaño de pelotas de ping pong
en un hoyo excavado por
su madre en lo alto de la playa.
De los 50 a 200 huevos puestos,
un 20 % nunca saldrá del cascarón.
Un mes y medio después de haber puesto los huevos,
eclosionan los supervivientes
y las jóvenes tortugas, tan pequeñas
que caben en la palma de la mano,
salen en masa a la superficie desde la arena
en una carrera desesperada hacia el mar.
En el camino: escombros, trampas, cangrejos,
gaviotas, mapaches y otras amenazas
vendrán por un 50 % de las que
emergieron de la arena.
Y las que realmente llegan al mar,
cambian un tipo de peligro por otro,
ya que primero enfrentan la repulsión de las olas,
y luego encuentran nuevos
depredadores que las esperan:
varios peces, delfines, tiburones y aves marinas,
al salir a la superficie para tomar aire.
En sus primeros días de vida,
en caso de estar entre las vivas,
las vulnerables tortugas nadan
frenéticamente hacia adelante.
En última instancia, a menudo
se asentarán en restos flotantes.
preferentemente en algas flotantes.
En los meses siguientes, tratarán
de evitar a sus depredadores,
encontrar lo que ellas mismas puedan comer
y de no caer en las presiones del clima desafiante
o de las corrientes desafortunadas.
En esta fase, un 50 % de las que lleguen al mar
morirán.
A la larga, con el correr de los años,
las sobrevivientes aumentarán de tamaño,
pasarán del tamaño de un plato
al tamaño de una mesa,
al menos en el caso de una especie, la laúd,
más o menos una década después.
El tamaño les da cierta protección.
Los únicos depredadores verdaderamente preocupantes son algunas especies de tiburones
--tiburón toro, tigre y blanco--
y la ocasional orca.
Al cumplir unas dos décadas
las sobrevivientes tendrán edad
suficiente para reproducirse
y continuar con el ciclo que requiere
su propia existencia.
De aquellos huevos en una playa distante,
ahora quedan menos del 10 %
al menos, esas eran las probabilidades antes de una intervención humana significativa.
En los últimos siglos, y en particular
en las últimas décadas,
la acción humana, como construcción en la playa
residuos plásticos, caza furtiva,
líneas de pesca, redes,
y químicos nocivos, incluyendo el petróleo,
han subido la amenaza para las tortugas marinas,
haciendo caer la tasa de supervivencia
a un 1 % o menos
de cada ciclo de anidación.
Es esta presión humana añadida lo que ha llevado a las ocho especies de tortugas marinas
a estar amenazadas o en peligro de extinción.
Desde hace mucho han evolucionado
para superar una serie de obstáculos,
pero el más reciente ha surgido tan rápidamente
y a tal escala que las especies se han visto
abrumadas.
Repasemos rápidamente este ciclo de probabilidades
con una temporada de anidación hipotética;
las hembras pueden anidar varias veces en un año,
1000 huevos, para simplificar.
Ponen mil huevos.
Rompen el huevo 800.
400 llegan al agua.
200 llegan a ser adultas.
20 llegan a reproducirse,
eso sin interferencia humana.
Dos sobreviven la edad reproductiva
con interferencia humana.
Así, una tortuga marina en reproducción
es la encarnación misma
de una carambola. Es la excepción, no la regla.
Una lotería. Es, en un sentido muy real,
un milagro.